let's do a makeover no
there's a one clear fix for pretty much
anything
from getting the guy to getting the job
or even becoming rich
and that's a makeover makeup check
contacts check a new hairdo also check
there are some tricks to a classic glow
up but not all of them have the same
results
or motivation the journey from ugly
duckling to swan
isn't as easy as it's cracked up to be
and it almost never works out how you
think
from clueless to mean girls and even the
hunger games here's how the classic
trope plays out in some of our favorite
films
and how it teaches us to look beneath
the surface
you must have noticed that the ugly
ducklings from some of our favorite
films
are never really ugly at all well other
than raggedy hair
oversized glasses and questionable
fashion sense yet they're often bullied
at school
have never been kissed and would much
rather stay home than go to prom
so what gives take mia from the princess
diaries
some bad styling goes a long way to make
anne hathaway look as plain as possible
once she transforms into princess mia we
can see that straight hair
makeup and contacts are all she really
needs to look the part of a princess
these makeovers seem to teach us that a
woman's biggest enemy is
frizzy hair the same thing happens to ty
in clueless already gorgeous she trades
her outsider fashion
and i just woke up like this hair for a
look that's put together
and approved of by her popular friends
disguises are another way for a shy
character to completely transform
take sam from a cinderella story she
only had to do her hair
put on a nice dress and throw on a mask
to become a brand new person
even though that tiny mask isn't fooling
any of us
these movies usually start out by
telling us that anything that hides or
transforms the true identity of the
protagonist
is a good thing that's why these movies
are known for the classic makeover
montage
these ducklings aren't usually alone in
figuring out their glow up
and half the time the glow up isn't even
their idea
just think of the plastics in mean girls
sharon dion and clueless the entire
beauty squad from the princess diaries
and the makeover queen who started it
all
cinderella's fairy godmother these teams
of seemingly helpful friends have
something in common
they all have some sort of control over
the main character
in the sense that they think they know
what's best for her they think that
transforming her will make her fit in
and change her life for the better cher
is one of the best examples of the
modern fairy godmother
control is the only thing she has in a
chaotic world
and she thinks that tai having that same
control over her appearance will make
her life
infinitely better by changing her cher
thinks she's doing her a huge favor
she even views it as a good deed the
problem is that these fairy godmothers
change these girls in their own image
they even see them as less fortunate
these characters are fulfilling a wish
but it's always important to be careful
what you wish for
the purpose of these makeovers aren't
really about self-improvement
are they instead they usually focus on
how other characters view the
protagonist
one of the best examples of this comes
from an unlikely source
harry potter and the goblet of fire
hermione's yule ball makeover represents
her transformation into a woman but it's
based on how
others see her including us hermione's
wild hair and no-nonsense scholarly
attitude might not have made her a
magnet for the boys at hogwarts but once
she puts on some makeup
does her hair and dons that pink chiffon
dress it's clear that harry and ron see
her differently
we even see her entrance from their
perspective and we don't get to see her
getting ready for the ball
her transformation is a sudden
metamorphosis
this image of the once plain girl
arriving at the ball and being seen
differently
happens to sam in a cinderella story and
in 10 things i hate about you
notice how patrick's eyes light up when
he sees cat dressed up at prom
a movie makeover might give a girl some
newfound confidence but the purpose is
usually to be seen completely
differently
in someone else's eyes in hermione's
case harry and ron
definitely realized that their friend
was also a woman and having victor crum
on her arm
definitely helped make it more obvious
speaking of crum
romance is one of the most common
motivations behind our ugly ducklings
wanting to become swans
just think of sandy changing for dany in
greece or laney from she's all that
becoming invested in her makeover
that was zack's idea not hers after she
starts to fall for him
just take a moment and think of how many
movie makeovers go hand in hand with a
love story
it's a lot isn't it but these romantic
motivations aren't always the same
sometimes our protagonist changes to
show an ex what they're missing out on
think cal weaver from crazy stupid love
these makeovers can also be based on
personality like when cameron tries to
become more of a rebel to impress bianca
in 10 things i hate about you
they might even have to do with romantic
revenge like in
john tucker must die when beth carrie
and heather find out they're being
played by jon
kate who's definitely not in love with
him agrees to become the recipient of a
makeover to try and
outplay the playboy some transformations
have
nothing to do with romance but have a
lot to do with pleasing society
just think of the devil wears prada
which raises questions like
can you even be a successful woman
without being pretty
how does the way you look and how
society thinks you should look
affect your chances at a great job or a
fulfilling career
sometimes changing into what you think
society expects of you
isn't always a good thing olive might
not care too much about her reputation
in eza
but she learns quickly that what people
believe about you can basically ruin
your life
these transformations are perpetuated by
women but they focus on a standard that
is beautiful to men
yep it's the dreaded male gaze in pretty
woman edward wants vivian to fit into
his life and social status
and her transformation is to please him
more than to make her happy
while the hunger games demonstrates that
being tough or strong or smart
isn't enough katniss must also look the
part of a winner
and a beautiful woman in order to be
respected even superheroes like captain
america
aren't immune from having to look good
to be successful though in steve
rogers's case
that means going from scrawny to strong
and imposing
while some of these heroines might give
in to how society wants them to look
some characters yearn to transform to
escape their place in society
cinderella might be the poster child for
glow-ups but she didn't do it all for
the attention of a handsome guy
she wanted much more than a prince like
her freedom a purpose
and an escape from her wicked step
family in the duff
this escape is from a label being the
designated ugly fat friend
isn't a title bianca wants by becoming
beautiful she can shed that title and
escape the way people see her
in pretty woman and the princess diaries
transforming also means reaching for a
new social standing with more money
power and prestige it's as though beauty
rather than
brains is the force behind creating a
better life
whether it's bianca realizing that she
didn't have to change herself in the
duff or katie realizing that life is a
mean girl isn't all it's cracked up to
be the swan
eventually realizes that she was never
really ugly and that changing herself
physically
won't fix the issues she has on the
inside some
like ty and katie even have to shed the
negative personalities they've developed
by becoming
beautiful others realize that they can
combine who they are with their newfound
confidence
gracie from miss congeniality realizes
that being pretty and being tough
don't have to exist separately and
though ally from a star is born still
wants to be a pop star after everything
that happened with jackson
she also realizes the grave reality of
being famous
so what's the message here that beauty
and talent won't necessarily bring you
happiness
especially if you have to give up huge
chunks of yourself to be the person
people
expect you to be transformation films
aren't always so predictable
sometimes they subvert expectations like
fiona in shrek who chooses being a happy
ogre
over a pretty princess we also see this
happen in book smart when the
protagonists make fun of the makeover
montage by not really changing at all
and she's the man and mulan our heroines
have to become men to be respected
and in legally blonde l woods proves
that beauty and brains
can co-exist transform transformation
stories may start out focusing on how a
girl should look but they end up
teaching us that beauty is more than
skin deep
they remind us that the impressive
person we all want to be is
inside us somewhere and we just have to
learn to trust that
inner us and let her flourish it's all
up to us and that self-reflection and
realization
is the true power of a good glow-up
which movies have the best glow-ups and
which movie tropes do you think we
should explore next
let us know in the comments plus don't
forget to hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and subscribe to the
things for more
thanks for watching